[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that's gone barking
[Music]
mad today we're heading back into the
wonderful world of blue the hit animated
show coming to us live from the land
down under now in case you've missed out
on this one blue is all about a family
of dogs known as the healers there's
Bluey her sister Bingo her father Bandit
and her mom Chile each 8-minute episode
sees them engaging in simple everyday
Adventures like playing keepy upy with a
balloon or preparing for the family
Barbecue all in a way that's super fun
for kids and super relatable for adults
this is great they're learning a lesson
and we get the house clean but what's
really made blueway iconic are the
episodes that focus on the wild
imagination games that the the family
plays which range from whale watching to
pretending there's a fairy causing
Mischief in the house to their dad
acting as a human claw machine insert
coin for awesome prizes legitimately
this is one of the best animated kids
shows that I've seen in years tackling
all the joys and stresses that are both
childhood and parenting in like the
purest way possible it is so good true
story I started watching the show with
Ali about a year ago and while he's now
graduated up into the world of Gravity
Falls I am so proud of you buddy I'm
still late night binging episodes of
Bluey and relating hard to Bandit but
the more I watch the more one question
lingers in my mind is magic real in this
world you see the imagination on display
as the characters play their games
really goes to the next level like
really these characters are incredibly
invested in their backyard Adventures
whether it's something like a very
aggressive puppet I can handle this mom
ow my back my neck my back and my neck
Whiplash call my lawyer to something as
elaborate as becoming an escaped monkey
rampaging through the yard
would you like to see our reptile
section and while most of it can be
written off as just parents committing
to the bit to like the nth degree there
are other moments in the show that seem
impossible to believe like the episode
where the kids literally learn to use
magic to influence their surroundings or
when Bingo uses a feather wand to turn
everything heavy seral
heavy what's going on and as you really
watch watch the show more and more of
these strange things keep popping up
these imaginary games seem to have a
ridiculous amount of influence on both
the characters and the world around them
enough so that I just kind of have to
ask is magic real in Bluey are all of
these games actually the result of the
characters casting spells hexes and
charms on each other well after digging
back into the world of Bluey and P out
some classic the tricks I believe that I
can definitively prove the answer to be
yes grab your wands and sticky geckos
friends as we dig into the Bonafide
evidence of the magical conspiracy
taking place in the world of Bluey now
on the surface you might look at a bunch
of these games and just think that it's
the imagination of children at work that
they're just very invested in their
games but there's commitment and then
there's just going Way Beyond what you'd
expect to come out of real kids at these
ages like to the point that these games
don't feel like a bunch of toddlers
playing makeb believe games anymore and
this is firmly on display from the very
first episode of the series in episode
one magic xylophone we see Bluey and
bingo playing with a xylophone that can
freeze anyone in place they just
straight up stop mid step in
mid-sentence at first Bingo and blue use
the xylophone to freeze bandit in place
and play some pranks on him and he
commits to the bit so much that he's
Frozen when the kids aren't around and
the Neighbors start giving him funny
looks now to be fair you could
absolutely just chalk that up to a good
old dad playing along with the kids but
here's the thing later in the episode
Bingo gets upset because Bluey won't let
her have a turn with the xylophone and
when she finally gets a hold of it later
on in the episode Bingo uses it to
freeze Bluey and it works if Bluey truly
wants the xylophone as badly as she does
and doesn't want to play along this
seven-year-old girl she could just
easily break the rules of the game and
take it from Bingo but she doesn't
instead she gets a pretty serious heart
to heart with Bingo well Frozen you
always never take turn with me and it
makes me feel sad now this wouldn't be
such a big deal if this was just a
one-off event but it's not this sort of
extreme imagination game is a common
occurrence throughout the series in the
episode feather wand again this is the
one where Bingo uses a feather to turn
things heavy we see her turn the toilet
seat heavy just as her dad's getting
ready to do his business and instead of
breaking from the game he chooses to run
downstairs and relieve himself uh well
it's unclear where exactly but it's
implied to be in the front yard based on
chil scream and Bandit greeting the
neighbor Ry what are you doing morning
Wendy I mean you could be committed to a
game sure but in this moment Bandit's
exposing himself to his loved ones and
his neighbors in a completely
inappropriate way public in decency is a
literally a crime are you doing that
just for the sake of an imagination game
for your 4 and seven-year-old speaking
of being inappropriate there are also
instances like the season 2 episode
dance mode mode where the kids are given
three chances to flick one of their
parents' tails and
say which forces the parent to dance no
matter where they are seems like it
should be a fun game right well it would
be if the kids didn't decide to use it
on Chili when she's crossing the road
ooo shake it Chile morning Wendy now
obviously this is super embarrassing for
chile but look at her dance moves if she
were truly in full control of her body
and wanted to get out of the situation
she could turn away from the crowd of
cars so she doesn't have to face them or
use moves that move her further along in
the street faster instead she's shaking
her thing in front of Wendy's windshield
Wendy apparently is just the recipient
of a lot of these embarrassing healer
moments now again if this was just a
one-off event we could just ignore it
but it happens again to bandit in the
post office uh are you okay I'm fine
just ignore this this right here it's
just dis respectful to both the store
clerk and the massive line of people
waiting behind him even when the store
clerk politely asks him to stop Bandit
says that he can't if you could just
stop dancing for a moment I would if I
could mate hey wrinkle to hurry up it's
either magic or the healers just suck
and it's here when the games start to
affect their everyday lives when you
really start to see the pretend nature
of the games break down for instance
let's take a look at season 3's episode
sheep dog where Bandit pretends to be a
sheep to distract the kids away from
bothering their mom but here's the thing
when blue isn't looking sheep Bandit
still decides to break into Wendy's yard
and start eating her laundry he even
headbutts her in the rear end when she
threatens to bring in Chile that right
there again is a level of commitment
that's either the result of magic or
just extreme irresponsibility on the
part of Bandit also seriously Wendy has
got to be the most patient neighbor ever
to be living next to these public
nuisances but the thing that really
decides it is that even when the kids
stop playing the game Bandit doesn't
drop the ACT he is still acting like a
sheep 20 minutes later well his kids
been upstairs playing with the neighbor
and his wife is just wrapping up her
alone time is everything
okay yep all good here why is he's still
doing it when everyone else has moved on
from the game but perhaps most
compelling of all is Daddy drop off when
bandit has to take the kids to school
and they're running late and yet just as
he's running into the car bingo finds a
leaf and uses it to trap bandit in slow
motion re him and stack him kids we got
to if Bandit's late getting his kids to
school you'd think that he'd just ignore
the game and get them in the car that be
the responsible thing he could make
something up about how School negates
the imaginary game or how this Leaf
isn't actually a magic wand or literally
anything so he can do the responsible
thing and get his kids to school on time
but again he acts like there isn't a
choice here he acts like he's been under
a magic spell the slow motion spell is
only released when Bingo waves the wand
again leading to Bandits smacking into
his car but hold on Bandit is released
from the spell when Bingo waves the wand
sure but she's standing behind him if
this were truly a pretend game there's
no physical way he'd be able to know
when she waved that wand we don't even
see his eyes moving or tracking behind
him to look at her watch the clip
again in fact we can actually go one
step deeper here's the scene in a video
editor where we can see the visuals an
audio track check this out Bingo saying
yah and the wand wave sound effect
they're right here they're actually
occurring after the wand is waved and
Bandit's released this right here shows
us that there's no way Bandit would know
to have sped back up again based on
sound or visual cues it can only be
explained using real magic and this is
how we know magic exists in the real
world for real life yeah Louie for real
life because we get physical proof of
magic existing like here where Bingo
sneaks into the bathroom Heavies Blue's
toothbrush without her hearing and it
just magically Works o that's
weird o it's heavy up to this point
Louie hasn't been a part of the game so
she wouldn't know that things are meant
to be heavy and while she could just be
pretending to not see or here Bingo the
way her reactions are animated certainly
seems to indicate that blue is unaware
of anything that's going on but the
piece of evidence that really seals it
the one that is irrefutable and
definitely proves that magic exists in
this world happens a bit later that same
episode at the top of the episode we
watch as Bingo uses the feather wand to
make her dad's cereal box bowl and Spoon
heavy forcing them all to the floor and
throughout the episode we check in on
Bandit as he attempts to prepare his
breakfast but there's one moment that
absolutely stands out what's wrong
Bandit you used to be able to lift
spoons did you catch it here as Bandit
tries to use this broom and rugby ball
to pry the spoon off the floor the broom
physically bends and that ball is
squeezed under the heavy weight of the
spoon and we see the broom Bend starting
at the spoon there is no way that this
could happen if the spoon was at its
normal weight literally no physical way
for that to happen therefore the feather
wand actually had to have worked on that
spoon giving us even more definitive
proof that magic actually exists in the
bluey verse and that suddenly puts other
episodes into a whole new context for
instance in the season 1 episode fairies
the Healer household is bombarded with
Shenanigans brought about by the dreaded
fairies you know what this means what
we've got
fairies now a lot of this episode is
framed as Bandit trying to make up to
bingo for ignoring her earlier in the
day and on a surface level you might
just watch this episode and think that
the parents are making the magic happen
for their kids but for as much as the
parents here could have made some of the
things in the episode happen there is no
way they did all of it for instance
Midway through the episode everyone's
hiding in the closet and bingo is tasked
with finding Clues as to what the
fairies might want in order to leave
them alone when she returns sometime
later The house's sitting room is a
disaster toys and trash are scattered
everywhere figurines are hanging from
the ceiling koalas just chilling like I
said this isn't Australian show it's
implied that Bingo was the one doing all
this but there's just no way in order to
hang those koalas from the walls and
that shoe in the middle of the room she
would have needed a step ladder that's
at minimum eight times her own height
and for as much as Chile and Bandit
disregard the needs and safety of their
fellow neighbors I don't think that even
they would allow their favorite
four-year-old to use something like that
unsupervised but still that little bit
it's happening off camera what about
something that's happening on camera in
real time that'd be pretty convincing
right well in that very same episode
episode after discovering a fairy ring
with Bandit's phone inside they turn
around and find that the entire yard has
been covered in fairy rings there is no
way that Bandit and Chile could have set
all of these up we see them in literally
every scene leading up to this big
reveal and if those Rings had already
been there Bingo and Bluey would have
already seen them and if they're just
pretending to not see them you wouldn't
get a bingo reaction looking like this
her eyes are huge she is shooketh by
those rings but we don't just have to
assume here either again we get physical
proof that they weren't there a second
ago go well the camera does its best to
try and frame out the rest of the yard
for the bulk of the scene look at where
blue is standing relative to that first
fairy ring if you map her position out
relative to the wide shot that we later
cut to technically we should have been
able to see that tablet fairy ring in
the bottom right corner of the screen
but it's not there until Bluey notices
all the rest of the fairy rings across
the yard this had to have been done
using magic so am I saying that fairies
exist in the bluey verse you bet I am at
the end of the episode Bingo straight up
sees a fairy setting up her dominoes in
the same heart- shape that Bingo made
for her dad well it could just be
imaginary and the show tries to leave it
open for interpretation all the physical
proof we have from bending brooms to
fairy rings to slow motion wands prove
otherwise and now that we have a couple
undeniable pieces of proof that magic
exists here so what I mean that's crazy
and all but why should we care about
this well we can actually track the
source of the magic and it's none other
than if you look back through all the
episodes and evidence you'll realize
that many of the imaginary games played
throughout the series are actually all
created by Chile using some form of
magic some examples in asparagus Chile
gives blue a piece of asparagus and
explains it's a magic asparagus it turns
people into any animal you want Chile's
Whispering this to BL so Bandit and
bingo can't hear her and know what the
game is And yet when Bluey
shouts Bandit immediately turns into a
donkey Chile's created a magic item and
is teaching her kids to do the same all
throughout the series magic that again
goes a bit too far when Bluey transforms
her dad from a peacock to a walrus and
causes him to Tumble out of a tree
landing on his back that's not play
along for the funsies that is risking
severe personal injury additionally
Chile's often shown to be able to
control the magic within the games that
blue and bingo come up with in the
episode magic when Chile sees blue and
bingo using Magic on Bandit the kids run
and she's able to stop them who taught
you how to use magic in fact Louie just
straight up confirms that she learned to
use her magic from Mom you use magic
magic yeah you can use it to make people
do anything mom taught me honestly I can
go on and on like in the ending of that
very same episode where bingo uses magic
to sit her dad down and force her mom to
the door all without dad looking
regardless I think that the one big key
takeaway of all of this is whether it's
extreme pretend or real magic the
healers would suck to have in your
neighborhood oh sure this magical family
may seem Charming to all of us happiness
starved Children of the internet for
their love and commitment to play but
that's us looking in from the outside
removed from the situation as we've seen
here today this one family disrupts the
flow of daily life for literally
everyone around them whether it's in the
line at the PO post office or when
you're trying to dry your laundry in the
front yard or when your name is luy's
Dad and you're getting mauled by magical
crocodiles get off attacked by magical
snakes snake get it off me or just noded
by lions oh Mrs Hill I don't know about
this imagine how it would feel to have
your adult neighbor pop out of a bush
and start gnawing at your foot there's
childlike Whimsy and spreading a joy
sure and then there's ass salt of your
fellow human a fellow dog creature thing
so while it might seem to be all fun in
games for blue and bingo living close to
these monsters would be literally
anything but but hey that's just a
theory a film Theory and
cut